Oppenheimer is one of the most
anticipated summer Blockbusters of 2023
and the movie's effects team made a
fantastic effort to ensure historical
authenticity and their Recreation of one
of the world's most harrowing moments on
July 16 1945 Jay Robert Oppenheimer
tested out the world's first atomic bomb
in New Mexico in the middle of an
isolated desert as recounted in the book
American Prometheus the triumphant
tragedy of J Robert Oppenheimer the
people who witnessed the test thought
that the world ended at the very moment
the bomb exploded this was a terrifying
and rather cinematic moment so it's no
surprise that writer director
Christopher Nolan had to adapt the
Trinity test for his epic biopic
Thriller Oppenheimer in a Roundtable
discussion with Entertainment Weekly
alongside some of the film stars Nolan
revealed and we always knew that the
Trinity test would have to be a
showstopper it's the fulcrum that the
whole story turns on Nolan was
absolutely sure about one thing after
featuring CGI explosions in his 2012
film The Dark Knight Rises a digital
version of the Trinity test just
wouldn't cut it so he asked Andrew
Jackson his visual effects supervisor
from tenet for help as Nolan explained I
wanted to take CG off the table and see
if he could come up with real-world
methodologies for producing the effect
of the first atomic blast Nolan
essentially wanted to peek inside up in
heimer's mind and come up with a
visualization of the quantum World
luckily for him his effects supervisor
felt comfortable in both the digital
computer realm as well as the analog
world as Nolan puts it Jackson is
wonderful with that and so we spent
months and months and months doing all
these experiments and figuring out all
these methods some very very small and
microscopic some of them absolutely
colossal Jackson teamed up with special
effects supervisor Scott Fisher and
production designer Ruth de Jong to
oversee the recreation of the atomic
bomb this thrilled Nolan even though he
told his crew that they didn't actually
need to go quite that far as the
Director explained mummy were trying to
make our budget work it was like well
what do you need to see of the gadget
itself I was like well we only see it in
these shots and those shots and they
ignored that completely from me Nolan
wasn't expecting his team to design a
version of the bomb in such exacting
detail but that was exactly what they
ended up doing which allowed the
production to move forward in an
exciting direction as Nolan recounted we
were then free to shoot the entire
process the shrink wrapping on it as it
comes up in the truck that gets cut off
the way that the different modules are
inserted in and wired up we were able to
build the tension up to the detonation
by showing that process that they went
through Nolan was able to use replicas
of the bunkers that Oppenheimer and his
colleagues were stationed in before the
Trinity test and during his aftermath
specifically production designer Ruth de
Jong built the bunkers in such a way
that they could shoot in the desert in
the middle of the night this allowed the
actors to essentially vicariously
experience what the actual historical
figures went through in the lead up to
the test Nolan is famously a stick lover
authenticity such as when he shot the
rotating hallways scene in 2010's
Inception with mostly practical effects
and it seems like everything came
together perfectly once again for
Oppenheimer from the weather to the
incredible efforts of the production
team in particular shooting in the New
Mexico desert paid off handsomely as
Nolan explained all of it just informs
the whole drama of the piece and the
build up to Trinity is the key it's
really all about the tension leading up
to it and the process that they went
through the revelation of the first
atomic explosion to the world was one of
the most important moments in 20th
century